okay playing The Gambler the gambler
yeah I've played this guy once before
with the drawn so what do we get what
Queens gambit do we get the classical
Queens gambit I could have played 9 p-5
here ah i am ok I think might be five
was puzzle I'll be interesting to see
afterwards I think it was possible
yeah this is this funny cards and
Ireland line with be five and a but I
don't only know it exists but I don't
know how it really is to be played okay
let's do it anyway c7 I think can that's
tricky business if he knows her if he
really knows his stuff there okay really
I don't know if that is right he plays
very quickly so it seems that he's all
he's like in in book yeah I think rook
that looks very logical putting it there
so maybe I should check on before arm or
is a form really necessary good news
do I get get the C pawn rolling
talk about an annoying piece on your
form but let's say just for argument's
sake I go a 4 here right I go a 420 392
just to to trade this I don't know if a
4 is essential known i think i have to
correct the queen the queen is bad on 3
b3 and he probably had a for the whole
time to be to be perfectly honest now i
was playing too quickly myself
so 92 now I have to have to get rid of
this night so FC
sorry for that I'm having a slight
called him and Bishop d6 I thought or is
this not even enough yet
I let he has to take a or a bishop f8
I'm sorry I bishop I made maybe that's a
move I can still just take it oh
interesting interesting
let's cover that thing what a weird
position
yeah I mean his pawn so there may be
some weird ways to return material here
maybe take on d6 96 98 or something like
that okay if I take e8 and then look c 6
i'm getting be sick so i think ok
buttcheek see a truck c6 that's also
pretty good so why not um yeah here for
rugby ain't using this the awkward night
damn and rook be aite group c 8 yeah
that's good wait yeah that's good c8 yes
to go up c 8 yard don't tell me you can
do anything fancy here oopsie aight i
take it Queen 85 Quincy
yeah sorry you missed 12 musait i got a
phone call and I couldn't have couldn't
get that on video that so I had to pause
the recording yeah so we we traded a
vendor oopsie to another thing action I
can pick up the night there I don't see
how he defended if he goes a to a cheeky
a check Andrew k it back and I have it
under control and I don't see a draw
their perpetual draw somehow I don't see
it mmm Quincy one and Quincy one cares
to Queenie three maybe seems like the
only only chance really ok so this check
here
check let's think for one moment okay
take check so I should be able to get
out of this Queen after year right
that's not blunder the rook that slack
resign this bad idea okay so yeah sorry
for this little interruption there I got
an important phone call yo so I probably
miss plate that I think this is the
right start of it c7 be 495 I think they
go a 4 here but he went the with this
played this every it's tough to analyze
there are so many possibilities there I
know what's wrong this is wrong it's
totally wrong I forgot that he has a
form i simply forgot about the idea and
this is just winning now probably yeah
this is this thing hmm okay roop c8
however and have to go a 4 again you can
play a forehead win but you didn't and
by now i had seen it and the computer
says what is this like about equal yeah
what a complicated position now i can
ship t6 here and rugby one now it seems
that i played it okay always keep an
advantage after I've I screwed up at the
beginning yeah King h7s is much better I
cannot take now because of a to it sets
a very funny tactic but I can play rook
ate something rook a2 b3 and keep the
advantage after that oli I'm winning a
flan flood winning him yeah okay wow
yeah I screwed up the opening there with
queen bee three but otherwise
interesting game okay well thanks for
watching